and now
to jen sake this is before she was uh
white house press secretary this is what
she said on twitter hunter biden's story
is russian disinformation dozens of
former intel officials say
well
that turns out not to be true if
anything you lady
are spreading disinformation oh and look
at this i got what they covered on 60
minutes last night very exciting they
covered russia obviously high rent
across the united states and uh
something about the wnba which i assume
three or four years from now will be all
men uh so just a lot of nonsense you
guys get it uh but saki and as i said
that was before
she was press secretary cause that was
right before the biden administration
took over uh she now is the press
secretary and she she just lies about
everything and she looks soulless like
she's
just deeply wounded inside so that is
the silver line to this thing because
eventually it does come get you all the
lies uh here she is responding to that
very tweet and that excuse about oh the
intelligence officials said it was you
know not real so you know okay good the
president has said and you have tweeted
that allegations of wrongdoing based on
files pulled from hunter biden's laptop
are russian disinformation there is a
new book by politico reporter that finds
some of the files on there are genuine
is the white house still going with
russian disinformation i think it's
broadly known and widely known peter
that there was a broad range of russian
disinformation back in 2020 okay
there was a broad range of russian
disinformation well she said
specifically that those guys said the
biden laptop
was russian disinformation but that
turns out to be untrue and and what are
you saying that the election was meddled
with have you have you done anything to
protect the election
since then i mean she's just
an endless liar
but it continued at the press conference
because the press is starting to get
some balls i don't know where the balls
are coming from but they're starting to
grow a pair and here
the questioner was asking about
biden's conflicts of interest with
russia
on russia you told me last year that you
were unfamiliar with the senate report
that alleged that the first son or a
company linked to the first son received
3.5 million dollars from the richest
woman in russia subsequent reporting
indicates that president biden when he
was vice president had a dinner in
georgetown with the same woman 2015. um
this uh yelling about arena she has not
been sanctioned yet by the u.s
government how is president biden
navigating conflicts of interest when it
comes to uh sanctioning people who have
done business with this family and can
you explain to us what this 3.5 million
dollars for i don't have any
confirmation of the accuracy of that
report so i have no more further details
about the conflicts of interest though
how he's navigating those when deciding
sanctions what would be his conflicts of
interest well his son's company
allegedly got 3.5 million
which i have no confirmation of and he
has continued to sanction oligarchs more
than we've ever sanctioned in the past
so i'm not sure that's a conflict of
interest
i can't stand there did you get what's
happening there so you know we're
sanctioning these russian oligarchs so
this is sort of the super rich class
that lives in russia these are the
people you see they've got yachts and
because they have yachts and they're
rich they must all be evil people i'm
not i'm certainly not defending people
that did anything through corruption but
we are sanctioning all of these russian
oligarchs but you know what's
interesting you're not gonna believe
this guys
the uh the journalist was right this
woman that gave 3.5 million to one of
the companies that uh hunter biden was
working for her name is elena batterina
and she's a russian oligarch but
for some reason she's not being targeted
by the sanctions according to and you're
not going to believe it your brain is
going to explode
the new york post
so i assume we won't be able to say that
soon enough and then the new york times
will report on it here you really get
that some really super crazy rich
russian woman gave hunter biden's
company 3.5 million dollars why'd she do
it i don't know um but that woman is not
being targeted by sanctions uh as all
the oligarchs are all the oligarchs are
and they're going after everybody else
really makes you wonder